if a writer is being ignored by
hollywood is that a sign that possibly
their work is just not ready yet
maybe it's a great question so um
there's two things going on here um most
likely they're probably not ready
that's that's more likely and because
subjective business it's entirely
possible that work
is totally ready and just hasn't found
the right person at the right time
so how do you know which one is you with
your script
that's when we come back to this idea of
a high quality feedback system right so
first your internal system with where
you're developing it
and then when you get it to the point
where you feel like it's as great as you
can make it
then if you're an amateur you go to
screenplay contests or blacklist.com or
specsock automan
specscout.com or coverfly really great
places to see where you stack up
and the metrics i generally suggest are
10 places it could be an industry it
could be somebody that works it could be
a friend of yours that's an intern
at such and such production company it
could be one of the contests it could be
one of those screenplays exchanges that
i just mentioned
any of those things if it's somebody in
the industry that could be like oh my
god this is the best script i ever read
i'm going to turn around and give it to
so and so and they could do something
with it
that to me counts as an open door if
it's your friend
who went to film school with you that
doesn't count because unless that
person's you know spielberg's kid or
something right
so um it's got to be somebody that has
the agency to sort of move it move it
forward
out of 10 data points whether they're in
every contest
everyone's like google content is still
going to be believe me every contest has
an opportunity to break your career
they don't exist they're there to try to
help you right you know
there's one or two scams out there but
by and large they're trying to help you
they want your script to be amazing
so um so they're all data points so you
if you submit to 10
places in the industry contest exchange
whatever
and at least three out of the ten only
three out of the ten you are
getting an open door then you're
actually in a good place
that's the minimum right and by that
means an open door is you advance in
that contest
you get maybe a seven on the blacklist
or you're pretty high in the specs out
but you're basically
you're getting to the point where either
that organization is like oh we want to
keep you listed on our site because we
feel like we might want to take credit
for your success
right anybody advances that's what
they're doing if you
uh submit it to your friend who's
working at such and such and they
submit it up to the producer and like oh
this is interesting
we're not going to set this up but maybe
you come in for a general meeting or the
next thing you write right
that's an open door anything that's sort
of that counts as like
a longer term relationship escalation
that counts
if you don't get it if you get um
rejected by the screenplay if
blacklist gives you a three if whatever
if if it's a closed door
um then it's just a data point no big
deal okay it's a data point so when you
then you look at those data points
and if you're not getting if you're only
getting one or two out of ten
you know it's probably because the
material is not close
and then you go back and you go okay
well i thought it was close here's what
i'm doing here's what my comparable
movie's doing what's the difference how
do i close that gap
you close that gap by a high quality
feedback loop people that know what
they're doing people that'll give you a
sense and then you'll figure out
and then you go back and you resubmit
right if you are
getting um more let's say you're you
know five at it like half you have a
great script and half the places you
submit to you're advancing or maybe you
won one outright right great
so now you're in a different place now
you're for sure
ringing the bell and now it's a numbers
game that's when you double down
um and i did this myself when i was
first starting out and entering contests
we had a script uh me and this one
writing partner
and it made the quarterfinals of the
nickel fellowship and i was like
oh that's nice so um i'm going to double
down
15 more screenplay contests to that for
that script right
because i already knew that it was
proven and
and so then i had 16 data points and
what happened eight of them were open
doors of some sort and eight of them
nothing and one of the things that
breaks my heart is like writers come up
to me like yeah you know i submitted my
script like
two or three places and like you know i
only got into one or whatever but they
they don't they're not taking
subjectivity out of it you need data
points
right so of that one script and one of
those scripts we won the grand prize we
run ten thousand dollars
so if our script we've submitted to
three of those places by chance and they
all got projected and we just gave up
it was left ten thousand dollars on the
table right so
uh so you got to take subjectivity
subjectivity out of it by getting enough
data points
um and so uh and then once you
have something that's again you're
getting you know fifty percent at least
thirty percent but
you want fifty 60 70 percent of open
door rate they need to buy as many
lottery ticks as you can as many
festivals as you can
get that there's also other ways you can
you meet anybody you want in hollywood
this idea that the doors are closed are
ridiculous because
um all you need you just need to
you need to know how to entertain your
way into talking to people
i mean that's the truth and there's way
you know and usually the way most people
query
hollywood is ridiculous it's um what you
need to do is
um empathize with where the other person
is and approach them with an easy ask
maybe you ask them a question maybe you
look at their twitter account you see
what they're talking about
but you have um you have an organic
conversation with these people at
peer-to-peer um and there's lots of the
doors are wide open this myth that it's
closed is ridiculous
it's closed because you haven't thought
about them you've been thinking about
yourself
and you don't either don't have it in
this on the script yet you need to
you know spend more time developing the
craft or
um you actually have a quality project
but you're
selfish in the way that you're
approaching people you're annoying them
you know you're like a telemarketer or
whatever it's not gonna work
you know but if you charm your way you
know you can even there's a guy that hit
me up on twitter
who um he technically made all the wrong
decisions in terms of how to query
i tell people how to do it and when i
work with them and there's very specific
ways that have a very high success rate
this guy did all the wrong ways you know
he was completely talking about himself
me me me my project whatever but it was
so damn charming and the way he did it
i was like i'll give him a pass i
started talking to him and you know we
ended up you know
ended up working with him so um
charm is the most important thing but
like and it can even overcome
bad form but like there are just simple
ways of
again getting back this idea of it all
being easy you know people are like ah
i knew this one writer who thousands of
query letters and it was
partly and got like sort of no response
and partly because
he um he just had that old school
approach i'm just going to shotgun
all these people and i'm going to talk
about all my i got to establish
credibility so i did this and i won this
festival blah blah blah and it's just
noise
it's just noise nobody wants to hear
that but everybody wants to have good
conversations so you want to talk to
anybody in hollywood
look them up online see what they're
talking about getting organically get
into a conversation with them by talking
about what they're
already tweeting about on twitter or
whatever their charity is or whatever
they already love
and let it be organic don't be attached
to it let it be easy
and i guarantee you if they are true
kindred spirits
you will find something to talk about
and then at the right time they'll go
wow you're fascinating
what are you working on oh glad you
asked
and then you pitch but can charm really
be taught
because there's some really bright
people around here and maybe they're
just so used to being
very matter-of-fact they're not used to
i hate to say bsing but sometimes charm
can be equated to bs and there's a
there's a there's a time for that
and and and people can do it very subtly
and it works
but some people don't they're not they
don't do charm yeah
what happens to those people um
so um it's a good question and
um it's it's not buyer me but it's not
binary there's not
you have it or you don't it's there's a
charmometer right
how far along you know and there's some
people that are off the charts that are
super charming
and a lot of people in hollywood are
very charming in general
it's a business that attracts charisma
and sort of thing
um but for sure there are ways
we can allow that charming charismatic
side of ourselves to be
more present or less present
it's a choice it's a practice you can't
just some people can turn it on
but some people need more practice but
um
it's everybody's got it whether you're
sort of geeky or
bro or artsy or whatever your thing is
um emo yeah it could be anything it
could be anything
but like um there's a side of you
that's authentic and a little vulnerable
and human and humble
and um when you show up in that energy
um in service to somebody else again
i was the point that i was making before
is this guy was so charming that even
using the wrong form he got my interest
what i'm saying is you can actually just
even have average level
charm and if you use my my approach
you're going to get
doors opening easily if you've got the
goods
what happens is most people most people
are asking me how do i try out for the
yankees i'm like oh you want to try for
the yankees huh
what minor league baseball team are oh
miners i have to do that first
no no yeah dude you can't you're not
going to make the yankees you can
first go try out for a minor league team
crush it in the minors
now you have a shot at the yankees but
that's exactly what i get when people
are hitting me up they're going how do i
i got i just wrote a script how do i
sell it like well
you might be able to sell it it might be
great why don't you submit to a couple
contests and see how you stack up
and maybe it is maybe it's the best
thing i've ever read but chances are if
it's the first thing you wrote the
second thing you wrote
you know you're not ready for the majors
yet probably and it's the same way it's
like if you don't play baseball you
don't be like you know i was really good
in high school i'm gonna go play in the
majors
i mean maybe some phenomenal players can
play at 18 but like
you know amateur writers don't realize
levels and they don't they don't quite
realize that they're they're competing
against professionals
you know professionals that are at the
game you know in
in fact in the major leagues you know
you've only got this short window of
time when you can play in the majors
right
but like the professional writing game
you know you could
be 20 years old you're competing against
me you're competing about 70 year olds
you're bringing the lead you're
competing against
everybody that's alive and can breathe
and sort of think
so it's a wide pool and you have to
bring your game
um by understanding those levels and
understanding where you really
are um and then moving forward and
it's not a bad thing it's not a big deal
to be like okay yeah i'm here and i'm on
this part of the road
who cares because you know what at some
point if you stay with it you will
become professional
and okay that's fine and then um it's
all the process anyway so it really
doesn't matter that much
that uh it doesn't matter that much
um where you are along the road but for
damn sure it matters
that if you're at the early part of your
journey you're not thinking that you're
someplace else
you know and on the flip side after
you've won an oscar
after you've had a box office success
after you've had whatever
you can't then get so arrogant that
think that you know it all and you're
not still learning
that's where that sophomore slump comes
in that's where all that problem comes
in
it's the same problem that the beginner
has they're not in the flow they're not
feeling their superpower and leading
from their superpower
they're doing it enough to get in and
then they get some sort of success and
they stop doing it and they fall off the
cliff explain to me data point
in terms of screenwriting so when i say
data point i just mean
the numbers so if you talk about going
to 10 places in the industry that has
the potential to advance your career
um it's you know it's a way
calling it a data point is a way of sort
of draining out the emotion of it
because
you know i was uh helping with this one
screenplay contest once and it was
amazing because
somebody did this screen
the screenwriter um he didn't his script
didn't make it to the corner finals
and his response was go f yourself
oh okay which is such a
such a ridiculous it's so ridiculous on
so many levels
um into the point that i'm trying to
make here is it's ridiculous because
um it's just one it's one data point it
doesn't matter
when any screenplay you know contest
doesn't reject
that you should the sooner you forget
about it that it they didn't advance
your screenplay the better off you are
you're only looking for at least three
out of ten which means
seven out of ten are going to close a
door and as soon as you find out they
close your door just forget about it it
doesn't matter
and certainly when you get a door closed
on your face and your feelings are hurt
don't tell the people about it
like you were a child and you were
petulant um because this is a
small town everybody knows everybody and
um i mean you know nobody's really gonna
care and i don't even know what that
guy's name was and i don't care
but like on the scale of like emotional
maturity
um you know emailing a festival that you
didn't get into or whatever and telling
them to f
off that's pretty much the best the
worst
response you could you could have to um
show that you have the emotional
maturity to
to do well in this business do you think
rejection
is like a muscle and that it's just you
learn that eventually like it's
it just doesn't it doesn't it hurt as
much
if somebody punches somebody's arm it's
almost like
just the weaker arm's gonna it's gonna
oh but then after a while
you build it up yes and i would even say
the word rejection is loaded with
something bad the better way to think
about it is um
it's just part of the process you're
either winning this way or you're
winning that way
oh i thought my script was really good
but i submitted it to the blacklist and
i only got a two
oh that's interesting what was it that
those professional readers
saw differently than what i thought
because i thought it was amazing
and then you go in and you figure out
how to close the gap
so where's the loss there's no loss
there's no rejection it's all part of
the process